parce que ça aussi ça me choque pardon
aux chocs ça fait un peu vieux combat
oui parce qu'encore une fois je suis
vraiment pour que quelqu un qu un jeune
garçon ou une jeune fille que ne se
sentent pas dans le bon sexes à la
naissance qu'on les aide absolument pour
changer de sexe qui est moins de
barrières qu'un avait maintenant fallait
voir des psys des médecins c'était très
compliqué ça je suis à fond pour en
revanche qu'il n'y ait plus de sexe mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quelqu'un
guenzi sa garçons quelqu'un qu'on a
passé une fille boutique mais tu te sens
tu te sens aussi bien fico garçon tu
mets ça n'existe pas bassil a plein qui
le délit mais qu'ils se sentent comme ça
peut-être que toi c'est une énigme pour
toi mais ça va ça existe pour beaucoup
de gens que j'avais quoi
non mais je ne je ne comprends pas
monsieur peut-être le seul jeu vers
l'électro binaire en fait tu n'as pas de
nuances tu peux pas comprendre qui est
des gens effectivement qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de choisir qui se sentent entre
les deux toi c'est normal pas normal
comme ça pour une fois on est de leurs
mots on n'est pas de l'ormeau non il ya
des gens qui sont pas toi qui sont eux
mêmes et qui a envie d'être dans une
autre ville sont pas comme ils sont pas
femme et quand ils cocher une case il
était malheureux on va enfin les rendre
ni aux dires il se sent plus d'accord
avec matthew toi non maintenant il reste
que c'est bien que ces personnes qui
sont une minorité mais qu'ils aient une
certaine reconnaissance et qu'ils
puissent formaliser sur leur passeport
est à sim se sentent ni homme ni femme
et contrairement à ce que dit eric
zemmour c'est pas parce qu'on interdit à
certains enfants ou adolescents de dire
qu'ils se sentent mon genre et que ça
m'a complètement déréglé la société
c'est une minorité certes mais il faut
la respecter moi j'appelle film je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec guillaume
merci à
fait d'accord avec john parce
qu'effectivement ces gens qui se
sentaient mal à l'aise s'exile alors
lord lors des papiers voilà et ben enfin
ils pourront aujourd'hui on ne vient pas
le cas stan lee qui met des gaz
[Rires]
je vais
retrouver cette place là chaque fois la
personne est désorienté
témoins après son père a été gazés non
mais franchement orienté ses bouquins
samedi non pas du tout non mais
franchement ya un problème il doit y
avoir un truc sur cette chaise
effectivement haut niveau à part ça je
pense que c'est un côté
valérie va bien oui
parce que dès qu'on aide les gens qui
sont perdus à choisir leur sexe ou leur
sexualité aucun souci mais ça veut dire
que tu vas rencontrer quelqu'un j'ai pas
le lundi au bureau bonjour tu seras un
homme ou femme du nom mouloud où je
trouve lundi sion mardi je suis femme
qui a fait un chantier ni noir ni blanc
tu métis mais c'est pareil à la
sexualité tu peux être ni homme ni femme
tuer tuer des genres et moi je crois que
ces personnes ces personnes différentes
c'est une question de respect de dignité
pour elle c'est très important c'est ni
homme ni femme y est notre case
maintenant ce sera xxl c'est bien et
c'est la dignité du respect jamais dit
que je respectais pas sa medi servi
comme mathieu
johann ruf